all right youtube i'm dave rubin and
joining me on the reuben report today is
a 2020 democratic presidential candidate
and author of the book the war on normal
people
andrew yang welcome to the reuben report
uh thanks for having me it's great to be
here dave
i am glad to have you here i'm going to
give you props before we do anything
else because i like to soften up a
guest before we get into the hard stuff
um your team reached out to us
and not only did they reach out to us
about being on the show
they said you could say whatever you
want we don't want any advanced
questions
he has no intention he'll stay as long
as you want this thing is as open
and honest and real as it could possibly
be um
is that by design of how you're running
your campaign because that's that's
pretty freaking rare these days
uh i guess it is by design in the sense
we don't know any other way to operate
and i i think there are other candidates
that would have talking points and
various constraints but that's not how
i've gotten to this point that's not how
i qualified for the democratic primary
debates and we just want to keep on
doing what's natural for us is part of
what's wrong with politics right now
that people
won't do this type of thing that often
it's pretty rare to just
sit two three feet across from somebody
look them in the eye and try to figure
out what they think
uh i i actually had my mind blown that
this was so unusual
it took my running for president and
being in the race for a number of months
to figure out that
uh most interactions are much more brief
and scripted
and less personal and i know there are
some candidates who've
gone back and forth about joining you
but to me i'm grateful to you i think
this is an awesome opportunity to
introduce myself and the campaign to a
lot of people
uh and congrats on the work you do cool
well i really appreciate that and i
think we're gonna treat this probably
uh more differently than any other
interview you've done because i don't
have
canned gotcha things and i'm not trying
to get you i truly wanna
know what you think about these issues
or did i just say yep we'll find out
but i did tell you right before we
started i've never this is the most
questions that i've ever written for an
interview because
when i've been on your website for the
last week while doing the research on
you it's like you've actually
really staked out all of your positions
but before we get to any of that let's
just do for the people that have no idea
who you are because i think you've got
some real nice sort of energy
in the in the internet space that i'm in
but for the more mainstream people that
are watching right now
could you just tell a little bit about
your your family background where your
folks are from you're a second
generation immigrant et cetera et cetera
sure my parents met in graduate school
at uc berkeley
my father got his phd in physics my
mother got her
masters in statistics so very nerdy
taiwanese immigrants
my brother is named after the lawrence
observatory so he used to joke that my
parents got busy there but i'm sure they
did
so you'd think i'd be a west coast kid
but my
father ended up getting a job at ge and
schenectady in new york where i was born
so i grew up in upstate new york in
schenectady
and then in westchester county in a town
called katona
and so i grew up to me
it was i think a fairly typical suburban
um first generation born in this country
second generation immigrant
um child of immigrants uh we're an older
brother and we were very nerdy
i saw the comic books in your green room
and like i was like an avid uh
dungeon dragons player and marvel comics
reader and video game player
um so you did see the nintendo in there
we could live stream a little nintendo
after this
uh it's been a while so
you realize that that's what people
would rather watch than talking about
policy well that's what my six-year-old
would rather watch
because like i i cannot believe how many
freaking gaming videos there are where i
just walk into the living room and it's
like my six-year-old
watching like someone else play video
games that's particularly weird it's not
that he's playing video games it's like
he's watching someone else playing i
would feel better if he was playing them
yeah this is what your job as a father
is to achieve you know
so you're right that i guess this would
be very very highly rated programming
you wouldn't be playing video games yeah
all right well we'll see yeah we'll see
how much energy we have left after this
um so you went to you went to yale and
you studied
i actually went to brown i'm sorry you
went to brown tennis don't worry about
it yeah yeah
you went to brown and you studied
political science and economics correct
yeah before that i went to a boarding
school in new hampshire called phillips
exeter
so that's where it got weird essentially
how did it get weird well so i was
growing up
uh you know in my suburb a fairly
typical upbringing i think
i went to this nerd camp over the summer
called cty that was run out of johns
hopkins university
and then one of my campmates said she
went to this high school called exeter
in new hampshire and really liked it and
it seemed really nerdy and i was pretty
nerdy so i was like oh let's do that
yeah so i came back that summer went to
my my uh parents and said hey how about
sending me away to school
and the one of my uh
one of my motivations was that my
brother is was two years older than me
and was leaving for college and i didn't
want to be left
at home alone with my parents so i was
like why don't you send us both away
same here
um so i went to prep school in new
hampshire for two years
uh and then i went to brown yeah
economics and political so what was
weird about it though
i mean i you have any friends who went
to exeter one of the new england prep
schools no i don't know
no no i'm i've only lived in new york in
la i'm another weird breed myself well i
mean i had a lot of friends who went to
binghamton because you know if you grow
up in a suburb of new york all the smart
honor roll kids
uh go to binghamton um but
exeter is a very i appreciate the props
there oh that's true i mean
like like i went up and visited my my
friends there
um several times so uh exercise is a
very snooty
new england prep school and i did not
know what i was getting into when i
showed up there
i was 15 it was
a bit of a pressure cooker and i
actually went back to speak there as
like an esteemed
you know alum a few months back and so
it had me revisit
my high school years there because i
hadn't been back since i graduated
um and it was a really intellectually
formative environment like the education
was top-notch
there's also very high pressure classes
on saturdays and
there was this deep sense of where you
got into college was
your value as a human being like that
kind of culture
not that they necessarily made that
explicit but it was very much there
among the students
yeah do you think that was all good
because it led us you know put a certain
amount of pressure on you to succeed or
do you think there were drawbacks to
that
there were definitely drawbacks because
there were there were some kids i went
to school with that had real problems
and not just like oh they're stressed
out kind of problems but
like institutionalization um at least
one suicide i know of one of my dorm
mates is in jail
for um murdering his ex-girlfriend as an
adult so i mean
there are some things that like a lot of
human condition darkness
um that resulted from in part the
pressure
yeah do you think that that kind of
pressure is partly why
uh college right now and the
universities seem
so out of whack i want to talk to you to
you about that a little bit later as
well
but just the general state of pressure
that young people feel like they're
under which is why i think
some of your economic policies are so
directed towards young people right now
yeah but very much so i mean one of the
things i say in my book is that like i
got into
brown and stanford when i was applying
to college my parents were psyched
the acceptance rates for those schools
were 20 plus
when i was applying back in 1992. then
you look now
uh those acceptance rates are so i think
like nine and five percent or something
like that
so kids are under even more pressure now
to try and get into various competitive
schools
and then when they show up to these
schools the pressure doesn't stop
uh and so you have these epically high
levels of anxiety and depression
and stress in part because when they
come out of school they're
entering a really punishing economy
where 44 percent of recent college
graduates are going to be underemployed
and on some level they all kind of sense
this and so that like
instead of an environment of
intellectual exploration
college seems like uh like a culling
or like uh or uh or almost like
servitude or something in a weird way
and because of the the
record levels of both cost and the
school loans that were
loading up on top of young people so
that to me it is all tied together i
mean certainly exert
its own thing um but i think i have at
least some
exposure to the sorts of stress and
anxiety that a lot of young people are
feeling and a lot of it is because of
very legitimate economic
forces it's not just like in in people's
heads yeah did you have to take out
loans to go to college yourself
well i was under partial scholarship
from ibm
and then i took out over a hundred
thousand in loans to go to law school
which was my next great move
[Laughter]
um so when i graduated from brad i
didn't know what to do so i went to law
school
yeah you went to yale right i went to
columbia columbia where am i getting
yale from
uh did i just make this up all together
i think i just completely made that up
all right now that i mean there are
their worst mistakes to me
okay accused of going to yell
so you were so you go to college and
then you become a corporate lawyer first
right
yeah i was an unhappy corporate attorney
for five months five months
yes how miserable was it that you only
lasted five months you strike me as a
guy that could probably
kind of plow through some stuff that you
don't kind of you
so i'll tell you a story i'm not sure
i've told this story before but um
so i was in my first or second month on
the job
and my phone rings on friday afternoon
at 6 pm
and i was like oh let me pick up the
phone and i see and it's the
um the staffing coordinator as the
person who tells you like hey you're on
this assignment
and so then it hit me i was like wait a
minute if i pick up this phone i'm going
to be here all weekend
and then i was like what happens if i
don't pick up this phone and so i looked
at it and i was like huh
and i didn't pick up the phone and it
stopped ringing and then i just walked
out and just had a weekend
um and then i came back on monday and i
saw a friend in the office and said hey
how was your weekend he was like oh i
got a call at six o'clock on friday and
i was here all weekend working on
these documents and so i was like i
don't consider myself like a shirker or
a lazy guy
right but i was reflecting on my
behavior and i was like
you know i did not feel bad about not
picking up that phone
so i was like i need to find a job where
i'm actually excited to
pick up that phone um and so i realized
that
i didn't want to do this job long term
and it was going to get harder not
easier to leave
and so if those two things were true
then i should leave immediately
so i started thinking about what my next
step would be and i
uh co-founded this dot-com
um that ended up you know not working
out
but uh so that's what prompted me to
leave at the five-month mark
how hard was that decision because i
find this when i go speak at colleges
now a lot you see
like a lot of kids that are training for
one thing but they know it may not quite
exist the way they want it to exist in
five years so after you've gone to law
school
you've racked up some debt you've gotten
a job at a corporate law firm you think
you have a path
to suddenly go i don't want to pick up
that phone on a friday that that's a
major decision that's not something you
do lightly
it was somewhat rash um i was 25 and i
thought i'm never going to have
lower levels of personal obligations
than i do right now
even with my six figures in school loans
i was like oh i don't have
you know a wife and kids i don't have a
mortgage don't have any of that stuff so
if i don't try and do something
entrepreneurial now i may never do it
yeah so you did the dot-com thing and
that didn't quite work out no it did not
yeah do we want to go any further on
that or should we just accept that it
didn't work out it was just one of those
well it's one of those things that i you
know i
empathize with folks who are trying to
uh make positive things happen and start
businesses because there's a lot of
mythology around entrepreneurship
and the danger is that anyone who shows
up on a panel is like i went through the
tale of woe but then i ended up shiny
right and you can too and then
everyone's like oh
and the reality of it's really gritty
it's very difficult
not everyone has it work out a lot of
stress
and there's a lot of [ __ ] around it
too where any one of the things i say is
like if anyone asks you how your
startup is doing you always have to say
it's going great yeah it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter how it's actually
going so it's profoundly isolating
because you can't have honest
conversations about
what you're doing you know it's funny i
had a friend about a year ago that i was
playing basketball with so
i would see him once a week on sundays
and he had this little startup company
and he was always telling me it was
going great it's going great growing
going great and then one day i'm
flipping the channels and i see one of
those reality shows where they go into
businesses that are disasters and fix it
and it was him and it's him
and i'm like that's all you need to know
right there yeah so
so i went through that and i had a very
very deep
empathy for the folks who work and
struggle and toil in obscurity because
like that's 99 of entrepreneurship you
know it's a bit like parenting where
like 99 of it is not like
you know like like taking pride in your
kids awesome achievements like
99 of it is uh you know done in uh
isolation
and obscurity and trying to get the kid
off the ipad watching other people play
video games
yes that sort of thing um what did you
learn like sort of technically through
the
the struggle of kind of trying to build
your own thing and having it not work
out
i learned a lot um so
uh well one i learned that at that point
i was not strong enough to build a
successful business
and so that's one reason why i ended up
working for another startup
a company that was led by someone i
admired because i thought okay if i'm
not strong enough to do this now
then i should find someone who's
stronger than me and then try and learn
from him
so so i learned that um i i learned
about
my own relationships because when you do
something that you put your heart and
soul into like start a business
or in this case run for president yeah
that thing that thing yeah
that little thing yeah uh that you have
some friends that
come through for you and then you have
some friends that just disappear
uh so you learn that yeah like pretty
damn quickly huh
yeah um so you you grow a lot
individually
and people who've started a business and
failed like i feel like we all have
these battle wounds or scars that
uh you know if you talk to someone who's
been through it you have a real
shared commonality yeah you think that
gives you a little bit of the sort of
courage you need to do something like
this which is obviously a pretty
uphill battle well i will say for
several years after my business failed
um i was like well this can't be as bad
as my business failing
like it makes you very bulletproof like
i was you know owed still 100
000 in law school loans like and
everyone i knew knew that my company had
failed
and so you feel really beaten up but
then you realize that
other people still like you or respect
you or
don't or know nothing about you and so
you just like meet someone for the first
time they don't
think like oh you're a failure you don't
handle the card like this is how much
i'm in debt
yes you know it's like no one knows you
a hundred thousand unless you're dumb
enough to tell them right
so so you do know we're broadcasting
this on youtube
uh well you know i mean now i'm happy to
say it was loans i think in the past
though though my parents during this
period were just telling everyone i was
still a lawyer
because it was like easier for them than
saying that i was you know
this entrepreneur that uh had failed so
speaking of that actually you mentioned
the pressure you were getting when you
went to
boarding school but what kind of
pressure did you get from your folks
well my folks were not thrilled when i
left the firm but i said look uh
i'll figure it out like i'm not going to
ask you for anything and just
you know respect my my decision uh
and they saw that i was working really
hard so then they
you know warmed up to it over time you
know it'd be one thing if i would like
quit the firm and was like
doing you know um doing something really
frivolous but they saw i was
uh putting my heart and soul into the
business yeah so before we go further on
your
work adventure let's back up for a
second so because you studied political
science
was your family particularly political
were you political did you have a strong
political bent
before college and did that change in
college or anything like that
that's a good question uh i always get
one well i
i so i was a debater
at exeter and i went to the world public
speaking and debating championships of
92 in london and so i had an
interest in
philosophy and political science i never
thought i would personally run for
office
uh particularly the more exposure you
get and i'm sure many people watching
this
know this too it's like there's politics
in the abstract and then there's
politics
in real life uh and most people as they
mature into adults
want nothing to do with politics in real
life card five is all about that
yeah um so i had an interest in the
um abstraction of politics throughout my
college years but i did not think i was
ever going to run for office yeah did
you have a particular political
belief i mean were did you always
consider yourself liberal or progressive
or so i you know i came of age during
the first clinton term and so like i
considered myself a democrat
at that point
and didn't really participate that
avidly outside of presidential so i
wasn't
actively involved in local politics and
i was living in new york and as you know
new york is so
blue that there isn't that much to be
engaged with uh
um politically yeah and now i moved to
california which is
almost so it's uh i should be doing
something a little more purple i think
but that's why i do this online because
it's like
you reach everyone you got the true
cross section yeah okay so the the
startup
busts and you and you learn some stuff
from that and then you go work this is
now at
a health care technology company i was
employing number four at a small
software company
yeah so i worked in urban hospitals for
four years
uh trying to roll out this information
service where
surgeons could get access to the
pre-surgery
surgery information that was in paper
form they would fax it and we'd digitize
it and then
post it online so that now that sounds
kind of standard but that probably was
pretty
pretty cutting edge at the time right
yeah yeah it was
um i mean we we raised uh seven million
or so while i was there we
got went from zero in revenue to several
million um but i
was so burnt from the my own startup
that died
and another startup that i was at for
six months or so that ran out of money
and so when i was working at this
healthcare technology company
um i had a couple of side hustles
because i was like i need to be able to
pay my bills no matter what
um so i started uh throwing parties on
the side i was a nightclub promoter
downtown i think that's in your bio on
your website uh it may not be
it's buried somewhere it will now be on
your wikipedia
but what happened was i i had a birthday
party
in my late 20s and a lot of asians
showed up
and they liked to drink and then i was
like huh there's something here
and so then i had a party and then again
a bunch of asian children
i like to drink parties and
like hundreds of people show up and so
we
you know had a website and um
mini technology uh backend and database
and crm
under the name ignition nyc so i did
that as a
side hustle and then i also helped my
friend with his
education company high-end test prep i
was one of i was the first
instructor and i helped develop the
curriculum
while he was starting the company also
as a side hustle
and so that side hustle ended up
morphing into my becoming ceo of that
company several years later
but for four years i was working in
urban hospitals helping manage
information systems
so since you were big on the party scene
in new york city i feel like
contractually i have to ask you do you
get the asian flesh when you drink
um i get like the asian sleepiness
is that there's the asian sleepiness
that's different the white guy
sleepiness or
um well so i'll if i if i have is that
one thing
i'm actually not sure if the asian
sleepiness is a known thing but if i
drink i get drowsy
um and so i would have these parties and
be stone cold sober the whole time
yeah so on the test prep stuff uh since
i think you're you're you're 43
44 44 so i'll be 43 this month so we
took the old school
s-a-t yeah do you remember what you got
um i did well i was good at filling out
the bubbles
is that that's the first kg answer
you've given me do you want to give me
the number i
i wasn't planning on asking you this but
like i actually don't remember the
number precisely
okay but you did well i i did do well uh
yeah uh i i i'm like
thinking about it because um so i took i
remembered this number i took the sat
when i was 12 and got at 12 20
on the old scale oh jeez um and and then
everyone in my public school found out
that score and then it was like i was
like an alien
um and i did not i was like literally 12
years old so i had no idea why anyone
cared
um but i do remember that except okay
well if you got a 12 20 when you were 12
then
you're in good shape because i got a
1200 as when i was 16 or something that
was
got me into binghamton so it was pretty
decent so you did okay well i think
well one of the things i try and tell
people is like these tests
don't measure really anything that
significant yeah
and this is coming from a guy who ran a
test prep company that because
is that really what you realized there
yeah
yeah i i did you know it measures a very
narrow
uh narrow set of intellectual traits
and one of the major problems we have is
that
we're dehumanizing
um many of our young people through
teaching to the test
and having this hierarchical
arrangement where the hierarchy in my
mind obscures
many other human and intellectual
capacities yeah
so did all of this sort of lead to your
interest
in tech and ai and what eventually
becomes the big discussion around you
with ubi and all that
we're just all of these just little
steps that kind of
eventually fit into the sort of person
that we know you are now
the person i am today they're the robot
that you are yeah yeah
um so uh so
failed.com four years
in healthcare software and then
six years running a national education
company that had a very
high technology element like
asynchronous online classes and
and uh question databases and and
a lot of social media use
so at that time uh
when that company was acquired in 2009
that was
right after the financial crisis and the
financial crisis really shook me up
because i thought wow all of my friends
out of exeter and brown and colombia
who are on wall street were wrecking the
economy
it turns out right and so i thought
about
what that would mean for the
country long term where we were having
so many smart people leave ohio michigan
georgia
um uh ohio
to head to wall street in silicon valley
um and boston dc to a lesser extent
and la and it was going to be this
massive brain drain
from much of the country that was not on
the coasts for the most part
so in 2011 i left my
job to start this organization venture
for america
to help train urban entrepreneurs in
detroit
cleveland birmingham st louis baltimore
places i've never been honestly
because you could tell most of my career
took place on the coast though
manhattan prep ended up with 18 offices
around the country so i traveled a lot
for that but at that time
and i wrote a book about this called
smart people should build things i
became fixated on the fact that we had
so much uh human capital doing certain
things in certain places and not enough
starting businesses around the country
and that was a direct result of watching
you know the economy crash basically
well it was and even if you look at my
own experience so
you know i i you know was good at school
and uh
went to law school and then was plugged
into
davis broken wardwell this high-end
corporate
law firm and became the embodiment of a
transaction cost
where they were going to pay me six
figures to work on deal documents for
some
uh giant acquisition uh
and that was my highest use like i
thought to myself
this is a quote from the time i said
this law firm's like
a temple to the squandering of human
potential because you had some of the
top educational products in our society
doing
scott work essentially and so if you can
imagine
me going through that experience and
then spending six years training the
analysts at mckinsey and goldman sachs
and jp morgan and morgan stanley
and seeing another version of the same
thing where you had all of these
talented humans
who are almost getting beaten into
submission and being made into
sort of lesser versions of themselves
highly paid lesser versions of
themselves yeah
and then that set of activities
contributes to the near collapse of our
economy
so uh after going through that for a
decade i thought well we need to do
something
that puts people in position to do
something that's gonna make them better
human beings
and would be better for our economy and
society and so the
vision that i thought was the most
compelling
was starting businesses in detroit and
cleveland and st
louis and baltimore and so that's what i
did between 2011 and 2017
was help create several thousand jobs
in those markets this may sound like a
bit of an odd question but what do you
think it is about you
that you saw something wrong and you
actually did something about
it because i find this now all the time
like when it comes to just anything
that's happening in the country right
now related to censorship or political
correctness or
how out of whack our political system is
just everything it's like
everyone feels that something's wrong
they may be focused on a different
thing specifically but very few people
are willing to do anything about it
what do you think it is about you that
you were like i see what's wrong because
you probably weren't your only colleague
that was like
my potential is being squandered here
but people get the check and they just
kind of suck it up
do you ever think about that like what
is it about you so
i was 24 or 25 at the law firm
uh you know during those unhappy five
months and i said why am i doing this
job
and then it was like it must be for the
money so what do i do with the money
and so then i went to bloomingdale's and
i bought my family some nice presents
and then i gave them to them that
weekend and i was like okay this is nice
is this enough for me to keep doing this
job definitely not
and so i think in my case
um and my my wife now you know finds it
sometimes very annoying
um but i i have low regard for creature
comforts
like i really just don't care right
right you know like i'm perfectly happy
with
uh janky street food we tried to offer
you a lot of stuff in the green room
you wanted water this man can't be
bought
but but it's just like these material
things don't uh
make that much of a difference and
though just because the way my utility
curves are shaped
and i know that sounds incredibly out of
touch to say it's like oh of course that
dude thinks that but like
even as a young person i just found
myself caring a lot about certain things
and less about
others and so
in 2011 when i decided to start venture
for america
the part of it too dave is that at even
at this point so i sold a company to a
public company
and i i thought that what's wrecking our
country was that we have
so much talent and energy doing a
handful of things in a handful of places
and it needs to be doing all these other
things
and i'd gone through that arc myself i'd
been a failed entrepreneur and i knew
how brutal that was
and i thought if i could somehow form a
pathway that would help support
hundreds of younger versions of me and
you
to do something that would actually turn
us into better versions of ourselves
i was like this is like the best thing i
could ever do and i had this sense that
if i busted my tail for
five or six years i could actually make
it happen um and i
i at that point knew that that wasn't
true for everyone so
if it was true for me then i should
really [ __ ] do it
because if i don't then like i'm
shirking yeah essentially
um because a lot of people could look up
and say oh someone should do that
but it would not be realistic for them
to quit their job and
you know uh try and raise millions of
dollars and and uh
build it but i thought i could um and
uh it turns out i was right so that's
very exciting it's sort of just like you
you were young and like it's good to be
young because you do some crazy [ __ ]
pretty much right
this is true there was definitely some
youthful yeah uh exuberance
that baked into this time period yeah
it's funny because you mentioned the the
crash in 2009 and it's like you were
you know had friends that were working
at these companies and all that i had
i was a struggling stand-up at the time
so i had no money i mean i was
scrounging around
just to get on i look at you now look at
you now i'm on youtube man i got andrew
yang in here we're doing our just so you
know camera
this place is beautiful
it really is so thank you but i remember
i had no money and i was working all
these odd jobs and bartending and doing
all this i had nothing i really had
nothing
and i was struggling to pay the rent and
all that and i had a friend that worked
at lehman brothers and he was rolling in
dough but he was miserable
and i remember when the crash came i was
like oh well
i didn't lose anything because i didn't
have anything but this guy lost his job
and was
freaking out and had been stressed out
of his mind for the two years prior and
warning that this thing was coming and
all that i thought there's some real
there's something about perspective here
you know so maybe maybe it's good not to
always have something is the point
well that's one of the fun things about
entrepreneurship is that if you were to
chart
um and there's a crude measurement let's
just uh chart how much money i made in a
given year
it would be like
right and and so it ends up which is
very different than your friend at
lehman brothers which is like
and so if you're in like this mode then
you start equilibrating to making lots
of money and you
like develop like an expensive lifestyle
and you have friends who have the same
lifestyle
but if your income is like you know
highly variable then you end up
uh you know not developing a super
expensive lifestyle i think that that's
one reason why yeah
i even see that now with me just because
of the way youtube rev is so out of
whack which it's just a portion of our
revenue but like on any given month
it could quite literally be five times
what it is the month before
so just as a for the for the limited
amount that i am a businessman which i
guess i've become
you have it's like i know what the
numbers coming in and going out are at
least and it's like this is
a tough way to to operate a business
yeah and so what you do
because you know you're smart is you'll
be like hey tell you what like i'm
actually gonna
like adopt an expense line that's like
toward the lower end of this thing
and so so that that whereas your friend
at lehman like
if you get income from an employer
virtually no one
like could actually say i'm going to
pretend that i'm not making this much
money i'm going to protect you
right just by your title you're that's
it yeah you know what you're being made
okay so so all of this happens
and when did you start thinking maybe
kinda you know run for politics
how am i doing kind of thing well
all right so um over
so over my time at venture for america
uh the budget grows and grows so i put
in 120 000 to see the organization in
2011.
i asked some rich friends uh do you love
america um and then some of them said i
love america and they're being like
prove it yeah like but it's like
but it's 10 000 and so you know raise
120 that way
and budget grows and grows to five or
six million um train hundreds of
young entrepreneurs help create several
thousand jobs honored by the white house
uh
movie with an oscar-winning filmmaker
get gets made about us uh you know write
a book
and then i have the sinking feeling the
whole time where i'm like we're just
scratching the surface
of the magnitude of this problem where
now i compare it to pouring water into a
bathtub as a giant hole ripped in the
bottom
because while i was getting accolades
and awards for creating several thousand
jobs
our economy shed four million
manufacturing jobs that were centered in
michigan ohio
pennsylvania wisconsin missouri
these places i was working and then
donald trump wins in 2016
and he wins because of the aftermath of
the automation of these jobs in the
swing states
there's a straight line up between the
adoption of industrial automation in a
voting area
and the movement towards trump in that
area it's one of the strongest
statistical correlations you can find
so so strategically it was very good
what he did
to win right to just keep saying to
those people on bringing the jobs back
or something to that effect
yeah and whether it was true or not but
i'm just talking about in terms of like
just pure politic
of i want to win well he got a ton of
credit
for just acknowledging the problem and
the pain
and even the folks that heard his
solutions kind of knew that he wasn't
going to like magically bring the jobs
back
but they were just pleased that someone
gave a [ __ ]
and then the democratic response at the
time was
uh so he was like you know we're gonna
make america great again
and then the democratic response was
america's already great
and then the people that were listening
to trump were like no things are not
great
and in these communities i was blown
away
by the disparities between missouri
and manhattan or uh
detroit and san francisco like where if
you have you've done a lot of traveling
in
this past year i went to about a hundred
cities in the united states so
then you then you may know if you've
been around yeah
because when you fly between uh detroit
and san francisco you feel like you've
traversed decades and dimensions and
ways of life well it feels like we have
many different countries within our
country
yes you can use that there you go oh wow
well you know if i use that i'll know
where it came from
when you throw it at a debate but it is
true
yeah it feels like we're many different
countries uh
and so when trump won i took that as a
giant red flag where i said wow like
this is actually getting away from
us much faster than anyone seems to to
believe
that we're in the midst of the greatest
economic and technological
transformation in the history of the
country because i spent six and a half
years working with hundreds of startups
around the country
and even if they're successful they're
not going to create jobs at the scale as
what's being lost
in retail uh trucking call centers
fast food and accounting bookkeeping law
i mean one of the jokes i tell is that i
was a lawyer long enough to know that
you can automate away a lot of that job
so so with all the uh
ai advancement that's coming
around the corner the stuff that got
donald trump in the office is just going
to accelerate in a huge way 30 of
american malls are going to close in the
next four years
and being a cashier is still the most
common job in the country and the
average cashier is a 39 year old woman
making 10
an hour so what is she going to do when
the mall closes i mean it's not like
another store is going to be
hiring and so this is what i saw in 2016
where i was trying to unpack the actual
data as to
how trump won and why and then i saw our
country
was not having any conversation about
the
economic transformation that we're in
the midst of instead we're scapegoating
immigrants if you watch cable news it's
russia racism facebook the fbi
hillary clinton and it's like yeah all
of that was there
um but the real driver is the fact that
millions of americans
lost their manufacturing jobs millions
of americans will now lose their retail
jobs
uh the call center jobs the fast food
jobs and when it gets to trucking it's
going to be
an epic disaster being a truck driver is
the most common job in 29 states there
are three and a half million truckers in
this country
average age 49 94 men uh tens of
thousands of them are ex-military
average pays 46 000 a year it's one of
the higher paid
jobs for high school grads like what is
their next move going to be when the
robot trucks come
in the next five to 10 years yeah so do
you think part of the problem here or
part of the disconnect let's say was
that
while the manufacturing sector was sort
of bottoming out
that the tech sector in its own way just
the way we think of the tech sector
meaning facebook google
twitter all these things they were all
kind of blowing up and they were
expanding and expanding expanding
and then the media focuses on them so it
seems like there's a gajillion jobs and
tech is going to solve everything and
all of that
yet that's actually not reality like
there was just like this huge chasm
between sort of the
the optics of it and the reality of it
yeah and certainly the media narratives
are not helping
any but some numbers so people get a
sense only eight percent of jobs in the
us are stem
and 92 are not is it realistic to try
and train 92 percent to do the jobs that
are currently being occupied by eight
percent
probably not probably not if you look at
the success rates for
federally funded retraining programs for
uh displaced manufacturing workers in
the midwest
zero to 15 success rates is that
going to be enough when you're talking
about hundreds of thousands of workers
almost certainly not
and so you never hear a politician say
when they're saying like oh we're gonna
educate and retrain americans for the
jobs of the future
oh by the way we're [ __ ] terrible at
that
it's like but any uh objective study an
independent study
shows that we are indeed [ __ ] terrible
at it and so why are we talking about
doing something that
we were not able to do for the
manufacturing workers and i studied
economics
so economic theory says we'd retrain all
these people but that's
not how it's played out in real life so
you truly view
right now because of the way tech is
changing us and sort of the speed with
it
with which it's changing us you truly
view this as a unique sort of inflection
point in
in human history right yeah we're in the
midst of the greatest economic and
technological
transformation in the history of the
world what experts are calling the
fourth industrial revolution and i know
you had martin fordon recently
so he and i agree on most of the
major themes of this and
the thing that has convinced me is that
because of my work with venture for
america i was invited to all of like the
high level design sessions
and social innovation conferences
and i got a sense as to what people are
doing in this space
and nothing anyone is doing is going to
address
the fundamental set of problems okay so
now
all of that being said have you heard
about this universal basic
income thing i have heard something
about you have heard about this all
right
well i guess then can you define
universal basic income for
those who have no idea i'm giving i mean
this is a freaking softball man here you
go
yes uh universal basic income is a
policy where every
member of a society let's say every u.s
citizen gets a certain amount of money
to meet your basic needs no questions
asked
so my proposal the freedom dividend
would put a thousand dollars a month in
the hands of every american adult
starting at age 18
to do whatever you want and that's
universal basic income
it sounds dramatic now in 2019
but thomas paine was forwarded the
founding of the country
martin luther king championed in the
1960s
milton friedman and a thousand
economists signed a study saying this
would be great for america
also in the 60s and 70s it passed the us
house of
representatives twice in 1971 under
nixon
and one state has had a dividend for
almost 40 years where everyone in alaska
now gets between one and two thousand
dollars a year
so i know at first blush everyone
getting a thousand dollars a month
sounds
uh very dramatic and almost too good to
be true but it actually is very very
deeply
rooted in american thought and when you
say everyone you mean
the person that's from someone that's
unemployed
to someone that is worth 20 million
bucks they're both getting that thousand
dollars yep that's right
okay now how are we going to pay for
this thing right that has to be the next
question
yes so um so first it ends up costing a
lot less than
most people think um and there are a few
reasons for this
number one is that about half of
americans are already getting direct
support from the government
in some form so my
dividend would be universal but it's
opt-in and if you opt in you forego
benefits from certain existing programs
so the headline cost goes down a lot
very quickly so
so this is like someone that's that's
getting some other social
welfare or something and then if they
choose
to take the ubi so like what type of
thing would they lose like food stamps
or
yes so it's uh it's full food stamps uh
housing subsidies fuel subsidies
cash and cash like programs that we've
about 120
welfare programs most of which are cash
or cash like
so this excludes medicaid
but it would include food stamps and
most other welfare programs right and
can you
can you split the difference on that so
could you say i'm going to only take 500
a month ubi and i'm going to take
you know 500 so you can't so you have to
pick one
basically yes yeah and so i've talked to
people who are on various welfare
programs and they love the idea of
getting a thousand dollars on
conditional because they
dislike the case manager the reporting
requirements everything else
and so you can reduce the enrollments in
our existing program significantly
uh and so and it brings down the
headline cost very quickly
because if someone's already getting 700
in benefits then
the cost is 300 instead of a thousand do
we have good accounting numbers on
actually how much people are getting
like i'm gonna guess that a certain
amount of people it may be one thing for
food stamps
but when you talk about housing
subsidies and things like that that has
to be way more i mean
the one that i always use is that my
sister and her husband
live in new york city struggling to get
by they both have full-time jobs two
kids you can imagine
how expensive schools are and just
living in manhattan and the rest of it
and half of their building is market
price and half is rent subsidized and
then what happens is
and i know you know this is that
generation after generation live in the
same apartment
then for like you know 400 bucks and
then
my sister and her husband end up paying
4 000 bucks for a tiny
two-bedroom so that people's people
basically just get locked in these
programs
where if you were to say to the guy
that's living in an apartment for 600
bucks
here's a thousand bucks you gotta get
going
nobody's gonna do it you'd have to be an
idiot to do it basically well i i think
knowing what i know about new york and
the um subsidized rents it's not a
federal program i don't believe
and so like their situation might be
that they actually get the thousand
bucks and then they
it's helpful to them um but in terms of
the math
it ends up reducing the headline cost of
this by hundreds of billions of dollars
very very quickly
because people will either not opt in or
if they do opt-in it costs
a lot less than a thousand dollars ahead
so that's reason number one where that
reduces the cost from like a
top line let's call 3 trillion a year it
goes down pretty quickly
the second big thing is that the money
doesn't disappear
in our hands it ends up getting
circulated through the economy over and
over again
what i call the trickle-up economy and
so if you
see that it would end up increasing
consumer buying power and the size of
the economy by about
10 to 12 percent we would generate
hundreds of billions in new
tax revenue just on the basis of more
economic activity in our society
we'd also save hundreds of billions on
things like incarceration
homelessness services emergency room
health care and things that we're
already spending about a trillion on
meaning because people are going to use
that money for those things
uh either that or we have to we get to
spend less on it
so one of the examples that and this is
going to sound very politician-y so
i apologize but i was in new hampshire
and a
corrections officer in new hampshire
said we should pay people to stay out of
jail
uh because you gotta give me their name
and tell me you put your their arm
around them and the whole
you know i really have it up for a pause
i was like i was there and
um and and so
we we think we're saving money but we
end up spending the money on the back
end anyway
if someone ends up falling through the
cracks and they land in our institutions
our institutions are
incredibly expensive and
at least one estimate was that if you
reduce poverty in this country
you would increase our gdp by 700
billion dollars just on the basis of
higher graduation rates
better physical health and better mental
health so we're going to get back a lot
of the money
but the big change we need to make to
pay for this dividend
is that right now amazon trillion dollar
tech company paid zero in federal taxes
last year
netflix zero and federal taxes less than
you did on this
awesome operation and you know amazon's
investing billions in ai
it's going to be one of the mega winners
from uh
the fourth industrial revolution so we
need to have a mechanism where the
american people actually get some of
that
and so my big proposal is that we have
to join every other advanced economy in
the world and have a value-added tax
that then
gets the american public a tiny slice of
every amazon
sale every google search every facebook
ad every robot truck mile
and because our economy is now so vast
at 20 trillion dollars
even a mild value-added tax generates
over 800 billion
in new revenue so that plus the savings
from existing programs plus the economic
growth
uh plus the value gains enough to pay
for a dividend of a thousand dollars a
month
so i know that a certain percentage of
my audience they know that generally i'm
a small government guy or i want it to
be i want it to be as small as it can be
to function as a general rule so it
could be
it could be streamlined enough i want it
to exist well enough so that things are
working
without all of the fat and all of the
pork and all the rest of it um
but so some of my alarms go off here
when because of the idea of that this
would be federal in nature
so that a thousand bucks if you live in
say los angeles
you get you get next to nothing a
thousand bucks if you live maybe in
you know somewhere in the middle of
country you're going to get a lot more
is there any way you can
compensate for any of that or you or is
that not even worth thinking about in
your estimation or
well there are there are a few reasons
why it's good it's a good idea to keep
it uniform
number one is that there are other
reasons why people live in l.a often
uh not just the weather but but access
to pretty much it
but access to certain economic
opportunities so you're making a
trade-off
already and it's also very hard to
administer because the fact is if you're
getting paid more
to live in an expensive place a lot of
people would live in expensive places
that like sneak off and
right you know spend the money someplace
cheaper so
it's much cleaner for everyone to make
it uniform it also
ends up fueling mobility in both
directions because at least some people
might feel like hey if i leave la and go
uh you know go to arizona like i can
actually live much better
that you know it's like it will help
balance things out
what do you say just to the general idea
sort of i guess
the philosophical idea that if you just
keep giving people things
that eventually they just start doing
less for themselves
that a thousand bucks like yeah maybe
there's some place in the country that
you could live
then you could play video games all day
and smoke pot all day and not really do
much and that we're gonna sort of
we're gonna cushion people's ability to
to not just get
up and get going well not that people
want that but that just human nature is
oh i start getting something and
i can just kind of ease up a little bit
so there are three things
i would say first i agree with your
vision of government and the great thing
about this is that this actually does
not grow the federal bureaucracy
what we all hate is when you have money
just flow up to the pipes and then
disappear and then you know
never see it again and you don't know
what the hell happened
this actually puts the economic
resources back in our hands it's one of
the reasons why the only state that's
done this is alaska which is the deep
red conservative state passed by
republican governor
and it's wildly popular there like the
dividend is everyone's favorite thing
about what the government does
because it's not a giant government
program it's actually almost cost free
to administer and just puts money right
into our hands so i agree with your
vision of government
is that the last thing i want is like in
our a new army of bureaucrats running
around
yeah yeah so but do you fear that even
even if everything you've said is is
completely on point that any time you
just the way that the system works at
least now that
any time you try to put in a giant
federal program
that the bureaucrats and just that
middle management
part of the government will figure out
ways like you could be like it's real
easy guys we've got 320 million people
in the country everyone's getting a
thousand bucks the math works out it's
like it's all good
but that then just the process of how
government works
will create all sorts of other problems
well
if you look at the way they do it in
alaska it's actually very lightweight
like as long as they can prove your last
resident you're there it's like this how
many people you are like they have a
very
very low uh level
um administrative burden let's say so as
long as you can pull that off
which in my opinion like this is
where we have to go because
because as the economy is transforming
uh
and so so number one uh
i agree with your vision of of small
government if we can achieve it
and so i'm going to come back to it with
number three number two
is uh number two is the biggest
misconception about this is that it's
somehow going to reduce work
and what i mean by this is you put this
money into our hands it has a first it
creates two million new jobs immediately
in the economy
because just more economic activity the
smoothie shop hires someone
the mechanic needs a you know an
assistant like on and on through the
economy so basically people have more
expendable income
more shopping occurs yeah pretty much
the easiest way to say that yes okay
on the other thing though that it does
it ends up fueling a lot of the work
that right now
our market does not recognize um so
that's
some of the stuff that you've done
throughout your career like arts
creativity
entrepreneurship like a lot of that
stuff doesn't get recognized by the
market until
um you become you know frankly
successful
but also work like my wife does my
wife's at home with our two boys one of
whom is autistic
and the market values her work at zero
even though it's incredibly hard and
incredibly important
so it's not that putting this money into
our hands somehow makes us work
less it creates conventional work it
ends up
um also uh fueling the sort of work that
we want to do
so that that's uh number two and then
number three
is this notion of what's happening in
our economy if you look around
at the fact that suicides and drug
overdoses have overtaken vehicle deaths
for the first time in american history
our life expectancy has declined for the
last three years almost unheard of in a
developed country
you know the last time our life
expectancy declined three years in a row
i guess it was probably like in the late
1920s something like that
yeah it was the spanish flu of 1918.
it's like where that killed
millions of people and so
and this buzz saw is just going to
accelerate uh when ai comes in starts
getting rid of call center workers and
uh bookkeepers and accounts and the rest
of it um and so when you're facing
a set of changes that's this mammoth
putting cash into people's hands
actually the most
lightweight thing you can do some of the
other proposals that are out there are
the ones that we must avoid which are
things like uh
like a jobs guarantee or like creating
like a whole new array of
uh of subsistence jobs for so that's a
massive
difference you have than some of the
other democratic candidates right
because
bernie and i think elizabeth warren and
a couple others are talking about a
federal
jobs guarantee which which to me again
as a basically a small government guy
that sounds horrible to me like that
that sounds like indentured servitude to
me
yes uh one of the things that's like why
not just get everyone gray overalls
while you're at it yeah
right give us the uniform and we'll flip
widgets all day and that's it
yeah so i try and point out obvious
things it's like hey what if someone
doesn't like the job they have what if
they're bad at it what if they don't
like their boss what if their boss
doesn't like them what if the job
actually like you know turns out uh you
don't need it after a while
like if you're literally dependent upon
a government job to
survive and like actually have food on
the table then all of those things
become
existential and you end up creating a
whole new army of bureaucrats to
administer
this like uh massive jobs program so i'm
for infrastructure uh
creating jobs like because those are
jobs you know you need we need to
rebuild the infrastructure but starting
out saying we're gonna guarantee
everyone a job
is exactly what we have to avoid so so
when they say that when when you hear
them say that
do you honestly think that they believe
that is the right thing to
do or or even a feasible thing to do or
that they're just saying because it
sounds
if you're not really thinking about
these issues that hard to me saying free
everything sounds good it all sounds
good free college free this
free job you know all these things just
if you're not thinking it's just like oh
great free why not
let's do it if you're young and you
haven't really put the the
acumen in to figure out what these
things one of the dangers is that a lot
of these politicians have never actually
run a business worked in a business
understand what the mechanics of these
organizations look like on the ground
they're just lurching from press release
to fundraiser to cable news hit and they
don't
understand what a lived reality would be
for a person who has to show up and like
check in for their
their mick job like
um and the institutionalization of this
thinking it is sincere
like it's not like if you poke the
person who's for federal jobs guarantee
they're like yeah i was just kidding no
no i mean
like they actually feel that well they
feel it right but i guess feeling it and
knowing
are two different things well i mean
they believe it let's put it that way
they're sincere in their belief
uh and and so if you buy that we're in
the midst of the greatest economic
transformation in the history of the
world which we are
and then in my mind you wind up with
like a couple of major
models to try and respond to it
and my model is put economic buying
power in the hands of every adult as
fast as possible
and help us rebuild our own communities
our own lives our own families and like
find
new forms of work that we find
fulfilling and purposeful
the other model in my opinion is the
government trying to figure out what
sort of work we find
meaning being valuable and purposeful
yeah and this to me
is what we must avoid at all costs right
well it's also a self-perpetuating thing
right because then the government always
has to grow
we always have more people we will
always need more jobs so they will
always
keep bringing more and more people into
the system yeah and to give you a sense
of the immediacy of this as we're
sitting here together in year 10
10 of an expansion the u.s labor force
participation rate is
close to a multi-decade low of 63
percent
uh the same levels as ecuador and costa
rica wait say that in 63
of of working age americans are
presently in the workforce
so when we hear this thing about uh uh
job
headlines yeah that unemployment is at
an all-time low or this type of thing
that doesn't factor in that people just
have checked out right is that that's
basically what you're getting into yeah
and if you remember candidate trump in
2015 he was like oh this headline
unemployment number is fake news it's
bunk
95 million americans out of the
workforce
and now he's in office and he's like oh
like it's great
he was right the first time because if
you leave the workforce
you're not calculated into the headline
unemployment number it also doesn't
include the fact that 94
of the new jobs created since 2005 are
temporary gig or contract jobs
it doesn't include the fact that 44
percent of recent college graduates are
underemployed in a job that
doesn't require a degree so the headline
unemployment number
is at best misleading and incomplete at
worst
uh [ __ ] like it's it's somewhere in
in that range
right so what what about i think a
certain set of people would basically
say well all right some some of this is
making sense and i can see why i would
get rid of some of the bureaucracy and
you're not
you're doing a governmental program but
not totally expanding the government
but why not just do it for people under
say fifty thousand dollars so that you
don't need to give it to the guy
that's making seventy five thousand that
lives in kansas city who's got a decent
life
uh but why not just give it to the
people fifty thousand you know whatever
the whatever the number united
come up with sure there are a few
reasons so one of the reasons why it's
so wildly popular in alaska
is that it's universal so it's not like
oh uh rich alaskans don't get it
protocols it's like no you live here
it's a right of citizenship
you get your dividend and so by making
it so it's not a rich to poor transfer
you destigmatize it
you universalize it and then you make it
more politically popular because it's
just something that we all get as
citizens and owners and shareholders of
the richest most advanced country in the
history of the world
number two you get rid of any incentive
to under report your income
or to have monitoring requirements let's
say i'm married to someone who's
not working and then maybe we could be
like hey how about we file separately
and then you
make nothing and then you can get the
dividend and so basically it removes the
cliff
situation where you'd actually want to
earn less right
this is one of the things that i've
struggled with the most about this about
the general idea not the way you're
laying it out
but that i i don't like things that
de-incentivize people to make more
and i can you know you mentioned this
thing before about you could struggle
for a long time and then suddenly you're
making more and it's like
last year i paid more in taxes than i
had ever made
in my entire life before that and like
that so i don't like the idea that the
more
work you do the more value you bring the
more you sort of get punished
yeah and that's one of the problems with
our current welfare programs like
in the extreme examples a friend of mine
his sister is on disability
she was afraid to volunteer at a
non-profit because she was afraid
someone would say you're healthy and
then take away her
her benefits i mean what a terrible
incentive system that is
but most welfare programs are
constructed such that if you
flourish then you get less whereas if
you have a dividend
that's universal you know you do nothing
you get the dividend you do something
you get the dividend
then like your incentive is actually to
do something so why not just blow apart
so i think the best libertarian argument
that i've heard for
ubi is that basically if you want to do
ubi it's got the right idea
why not just blow apart the social
safety net as is take
because we know it's just a boondoggle
of middle management nonsense
with all the whacked out uh incentives
that you're talking about
why not just take all of that money
which do we even know how much money is
actually put into these things of course
so how much right now
um 600 billion give or take give or take
all right so why not take the 600
billion that are on programs that we
know are creating as many problems
probably as they're fixing
if not more and then do it that way like
do you think because it almost feels
like it's
like a little bit of a stop gap that
you'd still have to get to that problem
eventually
well that's the beauty of this um the
freedom dividend proposal
is that you have the 600 billion or so
and then you're saying hey guess what
like it's now a new right of citizenship
everyone gets it and then what's going
to happen is you're going to
dramatically reduce the enrollment in
these programs very very quickly
because a lot of people will be like i
prefer the cash and then
then this new incoming population would
just
opt for the dividend and then never end
up on these welfare programs so you
would end up
shrinking the enrollments over time in
the way you described you just wouldn't
do it all at once
because you know there are a lot of
people in very distinct situations
and this is actually much more
politically uh
feasible and popular than going and
trying to tear these programs up and and
you know from from the roots up yeah are
you worried though that the
that because states have different
things related to social programs
that i mean we sort of addressed this
already but just that different states
will deal with it so differently
uh in terms of how they're giving
benefits off ubi
that it just is going to create this we
may have a gazillion people moving to
one state and leaving another state or
the rest of it or you just think that
that's
well that's one reason why having
uniform benefits because right now there
are block grants that go to various days
in the states
do different things with it as you're
suggesting and those are the programs
that would be
swapped out for ubi so the more people
that opt into ubi
than the the like smaller those grants
would be
so parallel to all of this one of the
things that we hear the democrats always
talking about
is 15 minimum wage i actually don't know
your policy on that
well i'm for the spirit that if you're
working full-time you should not be poor
but if you were to increase the minimum
wage to fifteen dollars it would hasten
the automation
of all these fast food jobs that pay
nine dollars they're always
everywhere yes ipad that's it there are
all these hardware stores and like main
street retailers that are just scraping
by that are paying people nine ten bucks
an hour
you take that up to 15 bucks an hour
they're 100 gonna cut shifts cut workers
it's much better just to give everyone a
thousand bucks a month
it's an effective raise of six dollars
an hour for anyone who's working full
time it doesn't come out of the pockets
of small businesses
it recognizes uh parents and caregivers
and nurturers that the minimum wage does
not touch
and it's actually better for small
business because is that hardware store
gonna be busier if everyone has money
yes
and so instead of taking it out of this
hardware store and this is one thing
that drives me nuts about the left i
mean i've run a small company
it's like like sometimes people imagine
that like every business just must be
somehow made of money
it's it's totally not the case
particularly in this era of mega
consolidation
where you have these giant companies
just coming and running amok
like they're made of money sure but it's
like the average like uh
independent business made of money such
that you can just say hey pay everyone
15 bucks an hour and it's not gonna have
any effect on what happened there that
that disconnect in the left now where
they they do this with this 15
minimum wage because i agree they sort
of think that everything is equal so
that my small business where we have you
know five full-timers let's say in five
part-timers
is is equal to amazon which they're also
not thrilled with amazon they have too
many employees i maybe have too few
employees like
there's always some weird number maybe
if i had 27 employees it's the exact
amount that's right but i know even
right now we're hiring interns but we're
paying them because i don't want people
to work for me
free i want i mean i want them to feel
good about what they're doing you know
what i mean i want them to feel
incentivized in all those things um but
but that concept that you just hit on
there
how do we break through to that because
it seems so obvious to me you can't
tell a guy that's got a little business
just forget me just take
some youtuber who's got one employee and
wants to bring on someone else now
there's some kid that really wants to
learn youtube
and it's like he'd probably work for
free but i want to give him eight
dollars an hour
to me there's nothing wrong with that
but they would literally force you
to not hire the guy yeah um
and so that's again why i think this
freedom dividend is so superior because
what do you think they're thinking i got
what you were thinking now but what like
truly this this is the disconnect that i
can't
figure out like do they actually think
they're doing the right thing or does it
just sound easy
so you just say it 50 minimum wage of
course why not well
yeah so i think many people have come of
age in a time when
uh capitalism has become so corrupt and
extreme
that they are deeply skeptical of
businesses acting
morally which that's legitimate it's
like a lot of businesses are doing very
messed up things
and so they're taking from that it's
like oh these businesses are
systematically exploiting their workers
when
they have ample resources to do so and
so they're
imagining that all businesses are like
amazon they have ample resources
um and it's in part because they haven't
worked in like a lot of different
settings where they would understand the
distinctions between different types of
employers
yeah so you're giving them the benefit
of the doubt well you know it's like i
mean the intention the spirit is
positive it's like do i think that
people who are working full-time should
not be
you know like uh scraping to just
get by it's like sure right you know but
is that also part of the disconnect that
you
because everyone always brings this to
fast food jobs when they frame this
argument and they say 15
an hour because the average person went
fast food joint can't
live on a full-time wage and it's like
but that actually except if you're a
manager say at mcdonald's or something
like that that shouldn't be your
full-time job
there's another layer of an economic
problem there right yeah yeah there is
and mcdonald's is rolling out self-serve
kiosks in every location in the country
by by 2020
uh right now with the wage the way it is
so it's not like i mean automation's
going to come even if you do keep that
right right even if you lowered it
actually you could have the government
come in and say we have to pay you less
and they'd still be doing it right yeah
and then the question if you're the
government is like what is my
intention like is it that like no you
have to preserve that mick job
it's like well how about we just
automate that job and
then the question is what is that person
doing instead
and so there is this really important
uh evolution that we need to undergo as
a society which is to say
look the market right now is a highly
imperfect determinant of what
jobs we should be doing so if you take
these people
who are working in fast food restaurants
and these jobs get automated away like
in my mind they should be automated away
and trying to preserve those jobs
is not where we should be going but
there's also
this massive gap as to
what the jobs of the future will look
like it's one reason why the freedom
dividend is so important because if you
have
a town of 10 000 adults in missouri and
then you put 10 million dollars more
into their
hands then you end up creating not just
more jobs in the main street but you
also end up supercharging
their religious organizations their
nonprofits their community organizations
you create different forms of
opportunities for people
and that is to me the generational
challenge we're in the midst of is
trying to figure out what the jobs the
future look like
when the market is going to try and zero
out more and more americans
very quickly do you consider yourself a
progressive actually because it's
interesting because you said the thing
about slim government and i get it that
partly what you're doing with ubi is
that you want a simplistic
a relatively simplistic answer to a
complex problem because you don't want
the government to grow
but so often every policy and we've
talked about some of them here
with 15 minimum wage and guaranteed
federal job and the rest of it
that progressives come out with are just
expansion of government so do you do you
consider yourself just an old school
liberal do you consider yourself a
progressive is there some
overlap on that or something else it's
like i consider myself a progressive
because i
i think like you know i'm pro uh choice
on pro
gay rights and gay marriage like um i'm
pro gun safety like
things that i associate with progressive
values and vision like i
you know line up on um we'll get to all
those
oh yeah yeah uh i think for me
the challenge is that i don't think that
government is necessarily the
vessel to achieve every goal
and i believe more in people than i
believe in
uh government as a problem-solving force
yeah
so that to me that's an old-school
liberal which is which strikes taken
which strikes me as
different progress from progressive in
that they're always trying to find
governmental answers to things
so what i think is that government is
very bad at many many things
um and it's good at some things and so
we need to lean into the things that's
good at yeah so
what are the things it's good at well
one thing that's really excellent at is
sending large numbers of checks to large
numbers of people promptly and reliably
every month that's like a core
competence so we just lean into that
right you may not want to see that's
where my libertarian bell goes off and
it's like oh the best thing the
government can do is give people stuff
and it's like even if they're good at
getting the check delivered like
they're gonna have the job we got a
bigger problem you know what i mean well
part of it
and here's the argument i'd make is that
it's our stuff you know i mean it's like
our wealth
we're like we're the owners where the
shareholders it's not that the
government's like
giving me stuff that's not mine you know
like i'm i'm an
owner of the richest most advanced
country in the history of the world
we're up to 20 trillion in
uh gdp and we can easily afford a
thousand dollar dividend and
if a company does that it's just good
management like you know no one gets mad
at
verizon when they're like hey we're
taking the dividend up it's like what
are you giving these shareholders like
money you know it's like
it's just considered good uh good
corporate management and it's good
management of a society so i know you've
explained a little bit of how
you pay for some of this stuff but how
does this affect taxes
in general i mean um
to me we have to go where the money is
and the money is
uh in the economic activities of
companies like amazon particularly as
technology just keeps on uh getting more
and more efficient
and powerful do i think that our current
tax rate should be
more progressive like i do um but
i also try and convince people it's like
look
jeff bezos post divorce is worth like
120 billion dollars or whatnot
you can take his income tax rate to
whatever you want
and he's not going to end up paying any
significant proportion of that 120
billion
because most of it is an amazon stock
he's too smart to have a taxable event
so like income tax is not the way you
actually balance things out so that also
puts you really at odds with a lot of
the mainstream democrats right
because they seem to want to put the
progressive tax to make sure that these
billionaires don't exist or
like if you look at aoc's green deal it
was like we're going to tax the hell out
of the billionaires
but then at the same time she's always
telling you how evil billionaires are so
there's an odd thing it's like
we need the billionaires to pay for this
thing even though we know we can't
actually pay for it
but then also they're evil and we have
to get rid of them
well so one i definitely don't think
that billionaires are intrinsically evil
i mean they're the natural byproducts of
this economic system that we've had in
place for years and years
and and two like again i'm for a more
progressive set of tax rates
because we're anomalously low relative
to our own history and other developed
countries
but i don't see that as the actual way
to get the resources we need to do some
of these things
what about flat tax why not just flat
tax the whole thing
15 for everybody lowest 50 grand and
under you get nothing
you know taxes you're good to go and
then everyone else just pays the same
and we go from there well one thing i
will say is that if you were to one
reason i love the value-added tax so
much and that every other country has it
um you don't want to tax things that
you're trying to encourage
and i want to encourage uh jobs and
labor
in every situation so over time i would
love it if we get off of the taxation of
labor
income so payroll tax yeah like that
stuff actually
is the opposite of what you want because
you want people to work more and you
want
more people to hire folks um so one of
the reasons i feel yeah
as a small businessman i feel it right
like i'm paying the payroll tax i would
love to be hiring more people right now
yes and the biggest burden on you is
healthcare
you know it's like i've been an employer
and guess what like if you
like put me in a position where my
incentives are to make everyone attempt
and that if i hire someone full time
then i'm it's going to take my
cost of hiring that person up 20 percent
then i'm gonna hire fewer people can i
just pat myself on the back in front of
a presidential candidate for a second
sure i pay a hundred percent of my
employees health and dental
because i do because i just view it as i
want people to feel good about working
here because i know if
if they're happy and healthy and the
rest of it like to me it's
self-preservation it's like if they're
happy and healthy
they want to work here feel rewarded
they're going to do better work
i'll say dave i did the same thing when
i was in your boat for the same reasons
but i will say that our incentives were
to go
a different direction particularly if
you end up employing well nine dozens
i can already see that as we're
expanding it's like i don't think this
will be sustainable over
the next version in the next version i
was in the same boat it's like you have
a small team you're like sure i'm going
to pay for you all
and then the team grows and you're like
wait a minute like do these numbers work
out and the worst part is you make the
decision
and then your health care costs just
keep getting dialed up and up
every year at several times the cost of
inflation and what it does it
discourages
hiring growth so payroll taxes
the opposite of what you'd want you'd
want to somehow like get that off of the
backs of both the the business and the
worker
but our current health care system also
the opposite of what you'd want
is like the last thing you want to do is
make it harder to hire people
harder to change jobs harder to start
businesses and that's what our current
healthcare system does
okay so let's let's shift to healthcare
actually so you're for medicare for all
yeah
so first off let's just do the 101 on
that like what does that actually mean
in your estimation
so that's uh government provided health
care so medicare right now kicks in at
an advanced age
and so medicare for all generally means
that you lower the eligibility age and
you make medicare
available to in my case all americans
where does private insurance come in on
that because i can get on board the
basic idea this again it's a struggle
for me as a as a limited government guy
it's just like a hard hurdle for me to
get over
but i can sort of get there
intellectually the part that's now been
scaring me
is that some of the democratic nominees
are literally talking about getting rid
of private health care altogether
and to me it's like why would you
obliterate the marketplace i get it you
want to try to give something to
everybody whether that would work or not
we can get into that
but you don't have to blow apart all of
private insurance too which creates
competition and ingenuity and all that
yeah so i am with you in that i am not
trying to
outlaw or eliminate private insurance
i'm trying to provide blanket coverage
to americans uh and we can do it
the one of the reasons why i'm confident
we can do it is because we're already
spending
18 of gdp on a highly inefficient
healthcare system that's also providing
massive profits to private insurance
companies and drug companies
like the levels of
of expense are staggering like we're
spending twice as much as other
countries to worse results and so
we can make coverage much much more
i'll give you one basic example we don't
even negotiate drug prices
like can you imagine that like you know
it's like these drug companies are like
we're gonna charge you this am i all
right
but is the problem then if you hand that
or if you expand medicare well now
there's less incentive for them to
negotiate those risks or you're saying
you basically force them to do it
you force them to do it and so so that
you can get drug prices lower very very
quickly
you can like get access
up in cost down very very quickly but i
would not get rid of private insurance
for some of the reasons why
why you you think that having
competitive markets and
incentives to innovate i agree with you
and this is america
you know you're going to end up with
some uh gold-plated concierge version
right and you should i mean if you have
the money to do it why should you not be
able to buy into those things but there
are i'm not i'm actually not totally
sure i think it was bernie who said no
more
private insurance yeah and that that
strikes me as just deeply
dangerous actually i i don't know it
strikes me as anti-american actually
because you should be allowed to buy why
could you not buy extra insurance if you
want
yeah this is true well uh
i agree with you that there's a place
for private insurance and private market
and to me like in america it'd just be
unfathomable to me
that there would not be some uh
something available for people that
wanted to buy it yeah so you mentioned
the uh
profits that these companies are making
um
should there be a limit on what they can
make so
right like why not just let them make
whatever they want and
so i'll give i was talking to a friend
of mine who's uh
an investor in public companies and she
said she has never seen profit margins
[Laughter]
like this in the device companies drug
companies
some of the private insurers she said
that she actually started shorting those
businesses because she said there is no
way this can continue
she said it's out of whack with anything
she's seen in any any companies ever
so that gives you a sense of just how
extreme the profiteering is
right now it's completely out of control
uh what do you think about quality of
service if you if ever so now everyone
has medicare
and now we know that there's just going
to be more government paperwork and i
know actually through technology and you
we referenced this an hour ago that you
might be able to clean up
some of the mess and get some of the
paperwork off but even right now i know
with obamacare i have a
good friend who's a doctor and it really
it really challenged his practice almost
to the point
where he wanted to get out because he
was spending more time on paperwork
than on you know working directly and
that's something i i want to help
doctors with
i'm asians have a lot of doctor friends
yeah you notice that um so uh
we have to lighten their bureaucratic
load and the last thing i'd want
is to increase it on doctors because
they need to spend more time actually
caring for patients and less time uh
dealing with paperwork and the rest of
it so
how do you actually do that because once
you now have made a federal program
bigger
i mean i think you can see a sort of
theme in the way i think about these
things like
once you make the federal program bigger
that all the bureaucrats get in and
now more paperwork and more paperwork
and more paperwork and there's less
competition so they have less chance
to go somewhere else and do what they
want to do
so here's what i i think um i have a
different set of experiences on is that
um it's not necessarily the case that
dealing with the government on this one
uh is higher paperwork than dealing with
private insurance because i've i've
worked in the industry and private
insurance has you know like also like a
lot of administrative hurdles
and the trick is though that uh if
you're a practice you're dealing with
maybe half a dozen different private uh
and maybe not half a dozen maybe like
several
of these private insurers so it is
conceivable and i know this is very
counter-intuitive but it's conceivable
that having this uh
this expanded government coverage would
actually reduce paperwork on the average
medical practice
yeah all right i guess conceivable
conceivable that's that's a pretty
rare word for a politician to use but
i'm
with but i'm certainly with you on the
goal and and so that the three things
that so
i've been looking at what's making
americans unhappy
and there are three things that are
making us unhappy in terms of our cost
structures number one is healthcare
number two is education and number three
is housing
and so to me any competent
administration has to try and attack
those sources of really at this point
you could call it even hyperinflation
because
education and healthcare have
skyrocketed relative to any other
consumer product
in cost so before we get into some of
those those specific issues
philosophically how do you decide what
the federal government should do versus
what state governments should do so i
understand your argument of why ubi
should be a federal program but just
generally how do you think about those
things
well to me we're at a point now where
our government has been
decades behind the curve for a long time
and you can see it in sort of this
increased desperation in the american
people where we're looking around being
like
i mean so many americans have just
completely given up on government as
like a
you know a problem-solving force in our
lives yeah
most of us are like i'm just going to
avoid government if at all possible
i get it i mean i'm there i hear you out
there too
yeah so i'll give you a sense of my
vision for this
um if you were a business and you were
getting hundreds of billions of dollars
in revenue from your customers
every year you'd probably thank them
you'd probably try and make that process
easier and you might even celebrate it
so
i would turn tax day into a national
holiday
i would call it revenue day i would and
i would
auto fill our taxes because that's
actually very straightforward to do
based upon
um previous filings and public info for
like you know 88 of us and then i'd have
an election where you could choose
where to give the last percent of your
taxes and then get a thank you video
from that part of the government
and then just get a thank you video
generally just like this is like to me a
vision of like
a competent government that doesn't
treat us like crap so basically some
portion at the end of your taxes where
you could go well i don't want to give
you know you're giving you're given
whatever you're given i don't want that
much to go to military let's say
i'm going to give more towards you know
helping homeless people or something you
would choose a little more of a
discretion
yeah you'd feel like you had some agency
in it um and then you'd get like oh and
then the following year maybe you'd get
like a report being like hey here's
where
yeah your money went and this might like
marginally improve our attitude towards
our government like would it turn us all
like totally into like you know big fans
of the government like
no but um would it make us feel like
okay at least they're trying
you know at least you're like you you
had like a
cool video with um you know oprah and
the rock being like thanks
so this is our branding really this is
your pr party who comes in and it's like
well
this is just to me just like business
101 it's like try and treat your
customers
not like crap so
so that's that's to me like a
rudimentary step
you would take um to me the federal
government should be trying to solve the
big problems
and so what are the big problems uh it's
automation of jobs it's climate change
it's infrastructure it's things that
states and cities don't have the scale
for and about the majority of our states
have balanced budget amendments
which means they can't actually make
giant
commitments which is not a terrible
thing but it just goes to show that if
they're going to be any big bets on the
future of our society and our way of
life it's going to have to come from the
federal government
okay so let's shift with that with that
in mind let's shift to uh
to education again small government guy
but i
am the function of i've only gone to
private schools my entire life
elementary school junior high high
school i went to
state university of new york at
binghamton i was a poli-sci major they
must have
done something right through that so i
do believe that that is one of the
functions
of the government uh that being said
we're obviously throwing tons of money
into education and it's seemingly at a
point where we're seeing less and less
results because of that
get us out of this problem all right
so the first thing uh is that studies
have shown that 70 to 75 percent
of kids academic performance is
determined by out-of-school factors
so that's parental time number of words
read to the child when they're young
parental income stress levels in the
house
type of neighborhood things that the
teacher cannot really control
and teachers know this you know and so
right now we're going to teachers
hey take 100 responsibility for a
process that you can control 25 percent
of
and the educators are like well we're
going to do our best so
the data shows that if we wanted to get
serious about improving our educational
systems
what we would do is we'd give the kids a
better chance to learn by putting money
directly into their households
that's what the freedom dividend would
do it would reduce stress levels in the
house it would free up
maybe a little bit of parental time and
studies have shown that this sort of
cash actually improves graduation rates
and it even improves children's
personalities if their
households are getting some more stable
cash and there's not as much
stress and turmoil in the house so this
might sound counterintuitive but the
first thing you do to fix
education is you actually just put money
into the hands of
families and parents so the kids have a
shot at learning the second thing you do
is you have to pay teachers more
because the data also shows that a good
teacher is worth his or her weight in
gold in terms of educational outcomes
and one of the best ways you can attract
and retain better teachers
is by increasing comp and what do we do
about the bad teachers just to take the
other side of that for a second
so i'm pro charter and i think it's
ridiculous that we're tenuring teachers
at like the two year mark or something
and make it so you can't be paid
or you can't be disciplined or fired um
and so
one of the trade-offs for a higher level
of compensation would be
what you have to do is you have to
empower principals and school leaders to
be able to
build their own staffs and teams and
right now principals have their hands
tied by
union regs and whatnot so you have to
attack both sides of it as you want to
attract and retain good teachers and pay
them more
and you want to give principals the
ability to hopefully make changes as
necessary
so are you basically for as much school
choice as possible charter schools
whatever whatever it takes whatever a
parent wants to do
yes in effect yes i'm pro-good school
and and this is one thing that i that
blows my mind is that people are just
attacking all charter schools
but that's true i mean a lot of the
progressives are not happy with charter
schools they don't want
because they want something more
federally mandated or at least mandated
by the government
so they don't want charter schools to me
it's like choice choice you're a parent
if you can send your kids to a school
that you like and it's not the
government school that's right by your
house
why the hell not yeah i mean there are
excellent public schools and terrible
public schools
they're excellent charter schools and
terrible charter schools we should just
be pro-excellent school
[Laughter]
and saying that this entire category uh
of school
is somehow like a problem if you were
trying to steal man their argument i
mean what what what is the argument
against charge because i get it that
some of them aren't going to be good
but there are public as you just said
there's public schools that aren't good
have you heard an argument that really
makes sense on this
unfortunately i think the main argument
is a political one
where teachers unions hate charters
teachers unions are very very powerful
constituency
and so some politicians have said i'm
better served by uh getting behind
um this point of view yeah that's
probably the biggest thing that you have
to break right in politics more than it
does i don't mean the teacher union
specifically but just like that type of
thinking
yeah that we have a we have an answer
choice let people decide what they want
to do
and then there's some other equation
politically that causes the politicians
not to do it well yeah
it's interesting so i'm running for
president uh doing quite well
very hard to say yeah talk to me about
the numbers real quick because we talked
about this briefly
what's the donation situation because
maybe we can crack this i can't sit here
and endorse you but you know what i'm
saying
what are the numbers so i've qualified
for the june and july democratic
debates um i have 116 000
donors individual donors donors uh well
above the 65 000
donor threshold for june and july and
here's the fun thing yeah is that the
dnc
just announced the threshold for
september and october and it's 130
000. so you're knocking on the door
right now so i am 14
000 donors away from qualifying for the
third and fourth debates in september
and october
and if we could make that happen that
would be history making
because if we clear 130 000 then all of
the press accounts when they talk about
who the let's say 10 candidates that are
going to make it to september and
october are
uh andrew yang is going to be on that
list right so you're 14
000 off and it's and it's literally only
a dollar i mean this is just how it
works not not just for you but for
everybody it's a dollar donation you're
good so you need 14
000 more people yes now you understand
that because this is youtube
this is where you have to offer the
people something
you have to like be willing to do
something nuts you got to dump cold
water on your head or splash
we got another 45 minutes or so you guys
so you have a little time to figure out
what's formulated what will you offer
at the end sure what's up oh yeah this
will be fun okay
um if we get through this during my time
here with dave
yeah i will
pour this water in my head but that's
not good enough so then i will
um
like sing my favorite karaoke song you
will sing your favorite karaoke song if
we get 14 000
more minimum one dollar donations if you
qualify during
the duration of this live stream yes yes
i will
you will do both so it's the water on
the head and sing this i will sing the
karaoke song with a wet head
having having a splash of water in my
head
asian people love karaoke is this too
easy i can do something
like less asian friendly
where the hell were we okay choice so
school choice
all right i think i think we pretty much
got there on that one what what would be
very asian unfriendly i will disparage
my parents
i actually want to do that i love my
parents yeah yeah no i'm not i'm not
trying to make you just better
all right let's let's just move through
just so you do have on your website i
mean i think you've done the best job of
saying these are my actual
policies because a lot of times people
just don't know what politicians
policies are so let's just
plow through a couple of them yes so we
have over 100 policies on my website in
large part because
i'm a newcomer and i wanted to introduce
myself to
uh america as efficiently as possible
and i thought the most efficient way to
do so would just be to spell out exactly
what i would do as president is there a
weird thing for you just like as a
policy guy and it's someone that thinks
through these issues that we live in a
time that's not really a policy time
like make america great again it's a
good slogan i understand why people like
it
it's not necessarily a policy like we
live in a time of you know like
you know if you dumped water on your
head and sang karaoke
that gets you on drudge today or so or
something like that
and that's very reverse sort of i think
inherently who you are
uh wow so interesting so
it is fun that it turns out that a
rational
data-driven problem-solving approach has
its own emotional appeal to a certain
subset of voters
yeah and this is not deliberate this
just happens to be who i am and how i'm
wired
where to me if there's a problem you try
and solve it
and you know you listen to what the data
tells you
is that an advantage or disadvantage i'm
actually very excited about the fact
that it seems like there's a huge
appetite for that approach right now
among the electorate that is sick and
tired
of like the um like the arguing about
like uh various symbols and uh
culture war issues and things that are
relatively marginal
relative to the problems we actually
face yeah all right so let's actually
dive into some of the culture wars
though because the one
especially for me and that we're doing
this on youtube that's incredibly
important
is is the censorship stuff and and big
tech
and have these companies grown too large
i'm becoming a broken record here but as
a small government guy i don't really
want the government involved yet
with the amount of information that
google controls and owns over us and all
of these things and the way they
control all the avenues of communication
it's pushing my libertarian beliefs to
sort of the end of the road here uh do
you do you view this as a big issue is
it something you care about do you want
government involvement
et cetera uh it's a very big issue i
care deeply about it
uh and then the question we have to
figure out is
who do we want making these kinds of
decisions i would suggest that we
probably want to have some say ourselves
in these decisions in these decisions
which would suggest
that the government be an active
decision maker as opposed to just
letting big tech platforms make
decisions as are proxies
uh and at this point even some of the
big tech companies are throwing their
hands up and saying
we should not be making these decisions
do you think they want regulation at
this point but because not only because
it's
an impossible set of decisions but also
in a weird way that would ultimately
hold their monopoly on all of this stuff
once the government was involved
i think that they expect that regulation
is inevitable
and they're trying to make it like the
most benign
version for their interests that it can
be
so what what would your strong
preference be then like is the
government like are we talking about
breaking up these companies do you
like i always say this but it's like i'm
in california i pay my state taxes on a
california state website it
looks like prodigy in 1993. like the
idea that the government is going to
come in and understand
the epic problems you know a government
regulator is going to come in and
understand the algorithm and the rest of
what's going on at youtube
sounds so bananas to me it's like i
could only see this creating other
problems
down the road so you definitely don't
want government
like take like uh controlling it and
executing on it uh i think you do want
government
to be able to provide very very clear
rules and guidelines so that everyone
knows what
really where we all stand and in terms
of where i would stand
i think that we have become overly
sensitive to the fact that if someone
has an idea that
is something i disagree with that's
somehow going to be harmful to me
to either be exposed to that or to have
some sort of
contact with that person or organization
so one i think the government
does need to get involved i think the
tech companies at this point are
expecting it
and two if you were to create guidelines
i would want them to be
uh as mindful of the fact that
uh that we live in a country where
you know free speech is protected and
that people need to be able to express
different
types of viewpoints without feeling like
they're going to get cast out of
uh the public forum so you would
basically sort of treat them like a
public utility
that basically everyone should have
access to them and as long as you're not
breaking the laws of the united states
something like that that that's pretty
much where i'm at if i had to go
the government route it's like if you're
not breaking the laws of the united
states
i believe everyone should have access to
these things and then if you're selling
drugs on them or
involved in terrorism or something else
but beyond that it's like
if you're stephen crowder and you make a
joke or you're me and you talk to
somebody who who's
shady or whatever you know what i mean
as an interviewer or whatever it's like
you have a right to do all of those
things but if you're breaking the direct
laws of the united states
then there's something else yeah i'm on
the same page but
you know this is one of the struggles uh
this guy jaren lanier have you spoken to
him he's one of the internet pioneers no
he said something that really stuck with
me he said that the internet is
much better at transmitting negative
sentiments and ideas
than positive sentiments have you been
on twitter
and and and that has very profound
uh repercussions and so that that's
one of the reasons why people are
struggling so much with this
is that they feel like in principle you
and i are on the same page like look
it's almost not breaking the law like
people should be able to say what they
want
but then some of these negative ideas
and sentiments and emotions
are so viral
in such a propulsive way that then like
in many ways then like the natural
reactions say oh i guess you have to
clamp down on that
and then just like clamp down on this
that that and then it ends up being a
line drawing problem
and a slippery slope yeah so so
basically you just but
you're saying you have to suck it up
though right because that's the risk you
have to take you're going to hear some
bad stuff
yeah i i i think the real
there's like a saying it's like um it's
something like uh
you know train the child not the road is
that like
we need to make ourselves more resilient
such that if i see an
idea that i find antagonistic or
offensive
um that it i don't think that's
necessarily something that's criminal
yeah in a weird way this is sort of
personal to your campaign
because some of you you've gotten you
know i as i said earlier i think you get
a nice amount of coverage on the
in the online space and i think because
you talk about ideas and this is where
there is fertile ground for that
it's working but i've seen some of the
mainstream things on you where it's like
oh the
trolls of the internet like andrew yang
or the alt right or something like that
and it's like i'm so in this thing that
i
always know when i see one of these
articles i'm like if that's what they're
saying then it's obviously not true
but the piece that i would say is true
is i think there's a the sort of meme
makers the yang gang on twitter and all
that
they like you and there's a reason for
that and then the media doesn't know
the mainstream media doesn't know
exactly how to relate to that they can't
understand that memes
could be being made of this guy who's
talking about universal basic income
who isn't promising the world to
everybody so then they sort of have to
make it sound like oh well he must be in
bed with the
evil forces under the internet or or
something like that
yeah and i try and um say it's like do i
look like
a white nationalist to anyone that's
like you know i mean i'm freaking son of
immigrants and uh
um i feel like they you know
might not welcome me deju welcome to the
party
yeah it's like we're really doing this
thing wrong man yeah
something is going to miss so um
but it's so surprising to me my the the
treatment in the mainstream sometimes
has been very confusing to me well
because i've seen once or twice you get
asked this question
on mainstream things yeah it's like and
then it automatically makes you
defensive like as if you have some
ownership over it
and it's like that that's just why
people can't stay on mainstream media i
think at this point
uh yes i have had that experience and
it's
uh it's been sometimes uh difficult to
answer the same question
over and over again when you're just
like if you've seen any other interview
with me and like a similar challenge
like why ask me the same question i'm
just going to say the same thing
i did there yeah right we could just
press play you could just be walking
around with your
your iphone going well here's my answer
to that one um yeah there's like a
fixation
on it and the way i think about it is
that people on the internet
are actual real human beings who happen
to have that internet connection
yeah and uh and distinguishing between
them and
other types of citizens just strikes me
as bizarre
yeah it's like people on the internet
equals just people
they're just people they're not all
russian bots yeah well you know
someone inventoried um my uh
social media following and it came up
like 97 human so
it's that's got to be the best of the of
the crew
that you're involved in yeah that so if
you do the same exercise
on other politicians social media
followings you get much lower
let's just say there are a lot of bots
out there for some reason following a
lot of these candidates
uh beyond just sort of the gotcha
questions of mainstream media what do
you make of the general state
of media in general where it seems like
it's just you know
the short questions cable news i mean
just the state of our sort of paralysis
and
right verse left and trump this and you
know the focus on sort of all the wrong
things
i did not realize how institutionalized
the
media companies were until running for
president
and a lot of it is the format of a cable
news hit
where the most time you're going to have
is
five or six minutes typically and the
rhythm is so
abbreviated where uh
the odds of you having any kind of
genuine intellectual exchange
uh very low and so you just end up um
you know trotting out very similar
talking points over and over again and
the interviewers are
fixated on certain types of ideas and
talking points so so it starts to feel
very repetitive
it's one reason why we're screwed you
know
i'm trying man i'm trying to i mean no
it's one reason i'm grateful to be here
and i appreciate
this format because
the media institutions
are confused somewhat by my campaign but
they're
um accustomed to this very powerful
gatekeeping role
that is waning quite quickly
and so we're in an era of institutional
collapse do you see that across the
board no really
but i i think you're right i mean we see
this across the board the media
gatekeeping collapse academia for some
of the reasons you laid out
i mean i think we see this across the
board in in many industries i mean the
retail industry we can look at this that
all of these things are sort of
crumbling
and the gatekeepers are started freaking
out and i i sympathize with them i don't
want things to burn there's so many
great things in this country like
look at us like what an incredible
experience this is you know and yet
things are changing whether they like it
or not and because they're hanging on so
hard or something
that that's making it worse yes and this
is one reason why i'm so passionate
about
uh universal basic income and the
freedom dividend so we're living through
an era of institutional collapse
uh and when the closer you get to the
guts of many of these institutions like
the clearer it gets to you
and so what are we gonna do an example
that like maybe an academic example
or just something oh an academic example
i mean like it's very dark where you
have all of these people who get phds
and then they wind up
being permanent uh postdocs and adjuncts
and like they they're never gonna get
paid above a certain level they're not
there it's never gonna be a tenure track
position for them
and so they just wind up being
subsistence uh laborers at these
universities
um for uh as long as they can stand it
then eventually you know like
many of them um can't stand it or like
they
uh i mean there's even a tragic story in
the atlantic about like you know an
academic like dies early because of like
the stress levels associated with that
lifestyle
because basically the machine never
changed along the way right so years ago
you would have
thought i can get this job i can go here
go there move up the ladder or let's say
it's in the academic world there's a way
to get to become a tenured professor
where now
there just aren't as many jobs and now
yes but then but they've never come
clean with that
and like eric weinstein said this where
it's like the growth model is making
scoundrels
and liars of us all where it's like you
just uh [ __ ]
like incoming phds being like yeah
that'll be something for you and then
there isn't or a law school graduate
like the law school is being like yeah
they'll be a
a law firm job for you and there won't
be if they join the law firm they'll
never be a partner spot because the
firms aren't growing anymore
so uh there's just a lot of false
promises being laid out there by
institutions
uh and we have to evolve as fast as
possible
uh it's one reason why again if we get
this dividend done
then we can actually end up building a
whole new set of institutions that are
much
closer to our our own values and our own
vision for our own lives and our
communities and do the work that we want
to do
but but because of the current erosion
of institutions we're going to wind up
in a couple of extreme scenarios over
time
and so it may seem extreme to people
listening to this everyone gets a
thousand bucks a month
this to me is the most positive extreme
scenario we can formulate as fast as
possible um
the the negative extreme scenarios are
catastrophic
uh and they're they're coming faster
than most people think
well i think a lot of people do think
about it but maybe they don't know what
that looks like like the full sort of
collapse of this whole thing do you
think about that like i don't like
thinking about it or talking about it
because it's like you don't want to sort
of
give it air in a way you know well and
but that's one reason why a forum like
this is so important is that like a lot
of the other
media companies would never actually
give it oxygen um so
to me again i mean like how many
americans know that our life expectancy
is
getting shorter because of record
suicides and drug overdoses that our
stress levels and
anxiety levels and depression levels are
at record highs
this is that 40 of american children are
born to
unmarried mothers um up from 15
when like i was growing up and you know
it's like you know you can have
different points of view about marriage
but there's a lot of clear data about
kids growing up in single-parent
households and like uh you know
um negative outcomes as a result this is
where the haters are going to say you're
for enforced monogamy
i mean i'm not you believe in the fact
you believe in the family well i think
that
if you have kids and the data shows that
it's better
if like there are a couple of adults
around as opposed to one adult around
then you know we should be
trying to make that more common so one
of the things i'm proposing is like look
lots of single moms let's have like uh
places where lots of single moms can
live together
um and then they can just cook one meal
a week and then like feed each other's
kids and not have it so that the kids
always alone
i mean like like that to me would be a
very reasonable
[Laughter]
like thing that you would try to right
try to streamline and make easier
but the way the collapse looks is
disintegration
uh and and i learned this
by living and working in a place like
detroit for
a period of time where detroit had a
peak population of 1.8 million
and now it's population 670 000.
so you go there and there are tens of
thousands of derelict buildings
it's unbelievable i mean people really
can't believe what what it looks like in
some of those areas
yeah and so you have 30 of american
malls that are going to close the next
four years have you been to a ghost mall
i don't think so because they are also
eerie yeah that's got to be seriously
like well
yeah it's like it's like zombie movie
type stuff can you just you can't just
wander in right i mean
you've probably been privileged enough
to just wander and you know because
you've got to fix the repair you know
i mean i've been or even if you've been
to a mall that's like mostly
yeah i've been to those you're like a
dying mall dying sure
i mean i've been in you know like ghost
malls too i mean like the
so um
this uh to me like the rubber hits the
road when
we start automating away the trucker
jobs and and i'm
on the record talking about the fact
that look if you have three and a half
million
49 year old men who didn't think their
jobs are at stake
what are the odds that at least a few
thousand of them decide to park their
trucks on place is not supposed to be
i mean dozens of truckers protested in
indiana
a few months ago by doing something
called a slow roll so they started
driving their trucks slow
on the highway there but behind them was
like why are we all going so slow
they were protesting the digital
monitoring of their driving time
they were mad about that how mad do you
think they're going to be when it's
their livelihood on the line their life
savings they put into their like
mini fleet of trucks on the line do you
think if if
we would have thought about these issues
differently or if the right set of
people would have thought about the
technological issues and the speed which
with which everything's changing if we
would have thought about this
differently in a public way
say 10 or 15 years ago we might have put
up some barriers to some of this stuff i
i don't believe that those barriers can
actually be because i am a believer that
once
once the cats out of the bag once
progress exists once technology exists
you can't stop it i don't think there's
any evidence in human history that you
can
but do you think that if we would have
and maybe some people were
really thinking these through 10 years
ago that it would have
not let us here or that maybe the
boundaries of the sort of craziness
might have been a little different
there are things we could have done for
sure
um and it starts with a belief in our
people
where the
the counter measure for the lost
manufacturing jobs
was shitty retraining programs that
didn't work
the better counter measure would have
been like hey
certain companies and certain parts of
our society are going to benefit to the
tune of billions of dollars from this
globalization
you're going to lose your job most of it
was automation it wasn't globalization
so it's 80
automation you're going to lose your job
we're going to start
spreading the bounty to you as quickly
as possible and give you
a path forward same thing with trucking
168 billion dollars in potential cost
savings per year
by automating truck driving jobs how
much of that right now are the truckers
going to receive
probably zero right yeah right so elon's
basically gonna put these tesla trucks
out there i don't blame them for it it's
freaking amazing technology
a lot of people are gonna go out of work
because of it yes and
right the guys that are losing their job
they're not well they're gonna get on
the government dole then because they'll
get unemployment
perhaps right and wait why only perhaps
well you know it's true that they could
file for unemployment um but right now
unemployment benefits aren't permanent
right oh and so at least stop gap you
then have more government expense and
then and then
and then they file for disability right
um because uh about half of the
manufacturing workers that lost their
jobs ended up on disability
in various states uh and the two major
conditions um that they filed for were
mood disorders
and musculoskeletal problems was
generally a bad back
how many truck drivers you think have a
bad back all of them
pretty much if they don't right now they
will
yeah so so i mean 80
of trucker is having a marker for
like a chronic health problem so obesity
disease high blood pres like
diabetes high blood pressure like some
condition
so they'll wind up in on the uh
on the government
uh expense line in a very dark punitive
dehumanizing way that's going to be
debilitating
and so what we have to do is we have to
start owning saying okay if this
transition's on
then we should be taking at least some
proportion of this 168 billion dollars
and trying to create like a more active
runway we should have done that with the
automation manufacturing jobs too
that's why again donald trump is our
president today is that no one was
actually speaking to that
uh all right so let's just knock out you
got you got a little more time for me
sure oh wait no so i i didn't even like
so education is pay teachers more but
here's the thing about education i want
to uh hit
is that so many of the the dems are
talking about free college free college
free college
college is way too expensive we need to
bring the cost down
but only 33 percent of americans will
attend
college uh 67 percent will either
not go to college or they'll attend like
a two-year
associates or community college so we
have to do is we have to dramatically
invest
in vocational technical training and
apprenticeship programs right now only
six percent of american high school
students are in
technical training in germany that's 59
so think about gulf
and then we have to destigmatize trade
jobs we have to get micro of dirty jobs
and me
as president in the white house being
like these are great jobs
and then we have to get all these high
school kids to say like look college is
not for everyone
right now we're we're trumpeting this
fantasy that college is the end-all
be-all
college has gone up in price 250 percent
which is zone set of problems
but the six-year graduation rate from a
four-year college right now is only 59
for four out of 10 kids who are starting
college are not finishing within six
years because they probably should not
have been there are you ready to have
that blowout fight with bernie on the
debate stage
because when he says college for
everybody free college for everybody
and again it sounds good and i get why
he's saying it and then you say well
actually college isn't for everybody and
we need more trade jobs and things like
that
people people are going to say oh
somehow they're oddly they're going to
say you're the elitist like you know
you think only a certain well but that's
what they're going to say is oh you
think only a certain set of people
from a certain way of life deserve to go
to college and other people are just
gonna have to suck it up
with their crappy trade jobs i think
that's actually a more honest answer
but just the way the media frame things
i mean you that's something to me that
will really come to loggerheads if the
debates ever get good and get really
about
substance um you may see that exchange
on june 26th on the debate stage uh
because
it could be just me next door and i'll
give you a birthday present just like i
want to shout out on that
free college stuff yeah um i mean i'm
not and again it's like the minimum wage
it's like am i for bringing down the
cost of college yes
am i for pretending that's gonna be like
the cure-all for
like our current economic ills no
because it's not
and again the unemployment rate for
recent college grads is 44
that does not change if i make it free
it's like is it better for them to be
underemployed and not have giant debt
loads yes
but like is that going to be necessarily
the path forward for everyone no right
and plus the amount of money we would
have had to put in to
do that for them to then not have the
path to the job yes
so the what we have to do is we have to
go to the colleges and say why the heck
did you get so expensive
um and the reason they're so expensive
is that the ratio of administrators to
students non-faculty the non-teaching
administrator has gone up
150 percent um over the last number of
years so we have to try and get the
administrator to student ratio
under control all right so i want to do
a couple more on policy but just one on
sort of the idea
sure on the idea side um identity
politics which seemingly has become
the cultural issue and i think almost
every almost every one of the policy
issues is now rooted in identity
politics
so i think you can argue that the way we
talk about free college is somehow
rooted in identity politics certainly
immigration
is rooted in identity politics that we
we're sadly whittling everyone down to
you're an asian man and i must have some
judgment on you because of that
and this person's white and this
person's black and this person's muslim
et cetera et cetera
um do you view identity i've heard you
talk about it a little bit actually but
do you view identity politics as
positive as dangerous as a tool for
something
i i under it's like a lot of the other
things we've been talking about it's
like i understand the
um the sentiment and uh
ideas um around identity politics
um i don't think it's a great way to
[Music]
try and build consensus or bring people
together or get big policies across the
finish line and i think it's a
kind of stupid way to try and win
elections
and so i think the democratic party
needs to try and gravitate away from
identity politics and towards things
that would actually
bridge the gap um so that's one of my
missions
during this campaign is to make that
case to say look
i understand people have different
experiences i've had different
experiences
but if we're going to solve some of
these problems we have to
emphasize the things that will um bring
us together and not the things that are
going to
make us seem like we're living different
lives is so that must be pretty sad for
you to see how far
the democratic party has gone in on this
or at least some of the other candidates
that you're going to be standing on
stage with have gone with this
yeah it's been really interesting for me
because
like i'm i was um
you know it's like i've been like a you
know democrat and like i thought it's
like hey
it's like i'm just like you guys like
i don't mean the people on stage but
they the people that buy into these
ideas would look at you and go okay well
he's asian and
because of the way asians are
socioeconomically successful and
families stay together and all these
things
your markers of identity are the ones
that get punished i mean obviously
i'm sure i don't have to tell you about
what happened with harvard and the asian
students that they wanted to deflate the
numbers on and it's like
no one gave your parents from taiwan
anything when they got here but they
want
you to be punished because they worked
hard and now you work hard
well you know it's like the the asian
american identity
certainly it's got like its own distinct
place in like the
sort of like you know identity hierarchy
i suppose
um i would say a very precarious place
unfortunately
but like the case i'm making is like
look my parents came here to
uh to have a better life for me and my
brother and it's worked
and now i'm trying to give back um and
that's
uh you know been my experience as an
american i'm a very proud american and
um i want to try and make this country
stronger so that uh
my kids and and you know other people's
kids grow up in a country that we're all
still excited about
and we do not have that much time to
make that happen because things are
coming apart
very quickly all right so let's knock
out a few more how about immigration
that's not controversial well
uh i'm for a path to citizenship for
people who are here
and undocumented we have over 12 million
people who are here
trying to deport that many people is
impossible it would collapse regional
economies it would be
completely inhumane and so
the choices are one of three things one
pretend you can deport them even though
it would be like a
complete catastrophe on multiple levels
yeah and nobody really wants to do that
i mean i mean i guess someone does but
when you really say all right we have
all these people and what it would
really take
yeah it's in government forced to rip
people out of homes and all that stuff
yeah it would be
um it would just be like the worst
chapter in american history they're like
even try
yeah and we'd we'd be we'd fail at it so
so what is a pathway so i get path
you want to have an opportunity to do
that so what does that actually mean
they have to
first say i'm here right yeah and and we
all know that whatever path you create a
lot of people are never going to opt
into it because they don't trust
us the government whatever but if you
opted in
pay your taxes uh no criminal record
um and then you abide by these
requirements and keep a clean record for
a number of years i'm thinking like or
the official proposal we have is 18
years
and at the end of that time then you
would become a citizen
if you pass um certain requirements and
then in this
uh during this period then you have this
new class of citizenship that's
essentially like a
like a legal resident right and is there
anything they don't
get in that time because i think a lot
of people that are legal immigrants
new let's say a legal immigrant two
years into the country
looks at the illegal immigrant i mean
we're seeing this weird tension now and
i think in a lot of the hispanic
communities where they're going wait a
minute
i did what i had to do i followed the
rules i did all of those things
and now you're going to suddenly let
people who snuck in or used family
trickery or whatever it is to get in
they're going to somehow jump
jump ahead or get benefits that i didn't
get well
that's one reason why the waiting period
would need to be really substantial yeah
but we also do need to try and
rationalize our process for people who
are here and have green cards
for people who study um at american
universities
we should be fighting to keep those
people instead of kicking them out of
the country like if you come here and
get a
degree from one of our universities we
don't want you to go home and compete
against us like
stick around right you know it's like
it's a great place to
to yeah to build a build a life um
so there and we we do need to enforce
the border like i'm not someone who
thinks that
you know uh open borders are realistic
so so what does that mean though
actually enforcing the border
well we need to uh actually uh put the
resources to work so if you dig into
what's going on in the border
right now we have hundreds of open
positions that we can't even hire for
because no one wants to live down there
and the turnover is really high and that
service pays less than just about any
other service
so it's like huh let me see am i going
to go live on like the
southern border and get paid less and
like have very little room for
advancement and be away from like my
family and civilization like
like so so this this is the it got so
bad
that that service hired a big consulting
firm i think accenture
and paid the millions of dollars to like
figure out how to hire people just how
to get somebody down there
yeah and and i think it ended up like uh
getting them like 12
applicants or something like it was like
12 million
later they got like 12 applicants so so
that we have like
like actual just execution problems on
the southern border it's one reason why
the wait periods are so long
it's like you show up and you know you
you uh um
we're just understaffed there and then
you end up with sometimes very tragic
results
yeah do you think there's technological
answers to some of this
some yes most of it no like i dug into
it and was trying to figure out how
technology could help
and most of it is old school
unfortunately for now
yeah so you can sort of have
surveillance but you actually
have to have sort of people there
basically yeah most of it
yes yeah um let's talk about abortion so
i told you right before we started so i
am pro-choice i've been pro-choice my
entire life
i can treat people who are pro-life
respectfully and i've had many of them
on here and have had interesting
conversations i think
i think that the abortion one brings out
something in the national dialogue that
sort of gets to the heart of all of the
anger where it's like you know
if you're on the right you say that the
left hates babies and if you're on the
left you say that the wright hates women
and i think
that's just an absolutely false choice
but that's really what we're being
thrown out all the time
uh you are pro-choice but you want to
explain that a little bit
yeah i mean i agree with you that right
now it's getting culturally
freighted um but i think that
uh women should have the ability to make
their own determination it's a deeply
personal decision
um i mean in an ideal society whenever a
woman was getting pregnant she'd be
excited to like
you know like um bring the baby in the
world but
like that's not the world we live in uh
and so i i want to protect women's
reproductive rights in any way i can
uh and um do you have a cutoff point
is there a set amount of weeks or months
that at that point
uh well certainly i find late term
abortions to be
like you know really problematic
um but my understanding is that those
are extraordinarily rare
unless there's some sort of medical
circumstance and so i would be reluctant
to have some sort of
uh date cut off because again in my
view it should be up to the woman what
what to do
yeah so six months a woman has a
perfectly viable fetus at six months and
you would still give her that choice
i would yeah it's really tough i mean
i've heard a lot of good arguments
against it but
i i'll respect your position um
all right i've got two more for you
non-policy let's let's just talk about
the future
and i'm going to try to end on a
positive note if i i actually have that
rule too it's like
yeah let's say well i don't want to
because i tend to be i tend to be a
little bit
uh depressing not really though you know
it's weird because i think people think
if you talk about
serious issues that somehow you're
depressing or you're like
you know too much of a realist or
something like that
but it's like without this this is the
only thing that can give us hope it's
not just the slogans that
that are going to give us hope oh i
believe so so thank you for not causing
for not calling me uh depressing me yeah
i i may need you to dump the water on
your head either way at the end of this
day
let's see how let's see how this goes so
i want you to just paint two futures
uh there's the last two things i'm gonna
ask you i want you to paint one future
if things really go that that meltdown
route and continue to destabilize and we
don't heed the warnings and we don't
bring in leaders that can honestly fix
these things and then obviously the
positive one is okay we start getting a
handle on these issues
how does some of what seemingly feels
like it's spinning out of control
how does some of that actually come back
um like how do we reconstitute or so
give me the version if the version if we
just screw this thing up
like we have we've been in my view the
greatest experiment ever is the united
states
yeah and if if give me the vision of if
we really just don't fix these problems
what this looks like
in 20 years and then and then the
reverse of that so uh
in in 20 years if we uh
don't change our ways
you're going to wind up with the most
unequal society in the history of the
world
economically like a winner-take-all
economy on a scale that
we can barely imagine and we're already
at one of the most extreme points in our
history right now maybe the most extreme
point
but this is before technology and
capital converge
to really create
wealth at a scale that right now most of
us can can barely fathom
and unfortunately that wealth right now
is going to concentrate in the hands of
a smaller and smaller
group of companies and individuals and
the reverse will be true at the bottom
where people will be looking around and
their paths forward their livelihoods
are going to disappear more and more
one of the stats that i find most
depressing is that the rates of
interstate migration right now are at
multi-decade lows
in the united states so people aren't
moving for new opportunities they're
hunkering down
so think about what that means that if
you keep having the
opportunities diminish in these places
but people just hunker down and stay
that you wind up with a real degradation
of your way of life
of your culture of your society that's
how you see these massive drug problems
and then you pile some climate change on
top of that where a lot of these these
towns
uh you know are going to unfortunately
bear the brunt of a changing climate
um and then our government will not be
able to ever come to any sort of
meaningful agreement in solutions
you'll have polarization uh
ideologically around the country you'll
have this left and right
factions that really are just talking
past each other watching different media
channels
getting completely different news from
social media feeds and
fragmented media and
the the average americans way of life
will start to
to suffer and our faith and institutions
which is already collapsed will just
stay uh low and decline even further
that's
to me the path of least resistance right
now yeah you didn't throw in zombies or
alien invasion or any of that stuff
riding truckers and you know like
self-driving uh pizza delivery cars
which we'll find both delightful and
mildly
dystopian right they you know skynet
takes over the whole thing okay so that
that's the negative one now give me the
one if we start
getting a handle on some of these issues
so the
positive vision of the future is that we
realize that we're
in an age of unprecedented prosperity
and wealth and resources and we start
recalibrating the way we measure our
economy instead of gdp
which is a measurement we made up almost
100 years ago
we start aiming towards our own health
and mental health
and childhood success rates and
environmental quality and freedom from
substance abuse
and things that we're actually excited
about and say these are actually going
to be the new measurements
of economic progress we start
distributing some of this 20 trillion
dollar bounty
as fast as possible and then get
americans around the country
oriented towards actually trying to
figure out what kind of work that they
want to do what kind of work that we
want to do
we build new institutions to provide new
pathways of structure purpose
fulfillment and meaning
we start
holding more of these institutions that
right now are
bloated and inefficient we start trying
to
bring them back into align with the rest
of society in terms of
like their mission and resources and
alignment
and we have this american identity that
stands the test of time
and we're able to look up and say uh
we're excited about our shared progress
and that when that person wins even if
that person is different from me
or you know that person lives in another
part of the country like i'm benefiting
from that
because i'm a shareholder of this
country and when that person wins then
my dividend goes up a tiny tiny bit
all right since we did two plus hours
and i didn't try to get you
i just wanted to hear your ideas which i
have can you do me a favor
what's that can you can you just can you
can i win the whole thing you got it
dave
can you become president of the united
states so i saw so i said i talked to
the president united states no
can you tell mayor pete that i'm not
such a bad guy um
yeah really i mean in the scheme of how
silly this is okay here we go
i'm literally going to see him this
weekend in iowa
and i will say to him hey i had this
incredible two hour plus conversation
with dave rubin and you should really
talk to your team about going on
i will do that least i can do this has
been an absolute pleasure i think this
is what can fix
some of this craziness and uh hopefully
you get to the 130 well i have no doubt
you're getting to the 130 so i look
forward to tracking this
and uh how about we do this again uh
well maybe before your president but if
you become president then i'm certainly
coming to knock on the door
this has been a lot of fun so i'll tell
you what one after i'm in the white
house we'll do a special reuben report
from the white house
love it but two i'd be happy to come
back uh even before then
yeah let's do it my friend all right
thank you very much i really appreciate
it and you guys can check
out andrew yang on twitter and hashtag
yanggang and it's it's yang2020.com
right yeah that's right andyang2020.com